do you think Wikipedia has a
left-leaning political bias which is
something it is sometimes accused of
yeah so I don't think so not broadly
um
and you know I think you can always
point to specific entries and talk about
specific biases but that that's part of
the process of Wikipedia anyone can come
and Challenge and and to to go on about
that but you know I I see fairly often
on Twitter you know some uh you know
sort of quite extreme accusations of
bias and I think you know actually I
just I don't see it I don't buy that and
if you ask people for an example they
normally struggle
um and depending on who they are and
what it's about
um so it's certainly true that some
people who have quite Fringe viewpoints
um and who knows the full
Rush of history in 500 years they might
be considered to be path-breaking
Geniuses but at the moment quite Fringe
views and they're just unhappy that
Wikipedia doesn't report on their Fringe
views as being mainstream and that by
the way goes across all kinds of fields
I mean I was once accosted on the street
um
outside the Ted conference in Vancouver
by a guy who's a homeopath who was very
upset that Wikipedia's entry on
Homeopathy basically says it's
pseudoscience
um and he felt that was biased and I
said well I can't really help you
because you know it cites we cite good
quality sources to talk about the
scientific status and it's not very good
so you know it depends and uh you know I
think it's something that we should
always be vigilant about
um but it's uh you know in general I
think we're pretty good and I think any
time you go to any serious
uh political controversy
we should have a pretty balanced
perspective on who's saying what what
the views are and so forth I would
actually argue that the
the areas where we are more likely to
have bias that persist for a long period
of time are actually
fairly obscure things or maybe fairly
non-political things so I just give it's
kind of a humorous example but it's it's
meaningful
uh if you read our entries about uh
Japanese anime uh they tend to be very
very positive and very favorable because
almost no one knows about Japanese anime
except for fans and so the people who
come and spend their days writing
Japanese anime articles they love it
they kind of have an inherent love for
the whole area now they'll of course
being human beings to have their
internal debates and disputes about
what's better or not you know but in
general they're quite positive because
nobody actually cares on anything that
people
quite passionate about then hopefully
you know there's like quite a lot of
interesting stuff so I'll give an
example a contemporary example where I
think we've done a good job as of my
most recent sort of look at it and that
is the the question about the efficacy
of masks during the covet pandemic and
that's an area where I would say the
public authorities really kind of jerked
us all around a bit you know in the very
first days they said whatever you do
don't rush out and buy masks
um and their concern was
uh the shortages in hospitals okay but
fair enough
later it's like no everybody's got to
wear a mask everywhere it's it really
works really well and it's you know then
now I think it's the evidence is mixed
right Mass seem to help in my personal
view Mass seemed to help they're no huge
burden you know you might as well not
wear a mask in any environment where
you're with a giant crowd of people and
so forth
um but it's very politicized that one
and it's very politicized where uh
certainly in the U.S you know much more
so I mean I live in in the UK I live in
London I've never seen kind of on the
streets sort of
the kind of thing that I there's a lot
of reports of people actively angry
because someone else is wearing a mask
um that sort of thing in public
um
and so because it became very
politicized then clearly if Wikipedia if
you go to Wikipedia and you research
this topic I think you'll find more or
less what I've just said like actually
after it's all you know to this point in
history it's mixed evidence like Mass
seemed to help but maybe not as much as
some of the authorities said and and
here we are
and that's kind of an example where I
think okay we've done a good job but I
suspect there are people on both sides
of that very emotional debate who think
this is ridiculous hopefully we've got
quality sources so then hopefully those
people who read this can say oh actually
you know it is complicated you know if
you can get to the point of saying okay
this is I have my view but I understand
other views and I do think it's a
complicated question great now we're a
little bit more mature as a society well
that one is an interesting one because I
feel like I hope that that article also
contains the meta conversation about the
politicization of that topic yeah to me
it's almost more interesting than what
the masks work or not as at least at
this point is like why it became masks
became a symbol of the oppression of a
centralized government if you wear them
you're a sheep that follows the mass
control the mass hysteria of an
authoritarian regime and if you don't
wear a mask then you're a science denier
anti-vaxxer a um alt-right probably a
Nazi yeah so exactly and that that whole
politicization of society is it's just
so damaging
um and I don't I don't know in broader
in the broader world like how do we
start to fix that that's a really hard
question